[Music]
on this saturday night calls for
accountability following deadly delays
as funerals are planned in uvalde texas
they let a little baby get slaughtered
questions remain the calls to harden
schools data that says otherwise army
teachers is a really bad idea and a
family i think this time it's going to
be different fighting for change
holding their nose at the polls and why
thursday's ontario election results
could impact the rest of the country and
fashion police faux pas i thought i was
completely within the rules a denny film
producer is tossed from the red carpet
at can for wearing his traditional
footwear why he hopes it's a step
forward
global national
reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us the
inaction of police in uvalde texas sees
now the central focus of the
investigation into tuesday's mass
shooting and at elementary school
there's mounting anger that officers
stood by while children were gunned down
inside a classroom 19 young students and
two teachers were killed police admit it
was the wrong decision not to breach the
room sooner and grieving families are
now wondering if their loved ones might
still be alive had they done so jennifer
johnson has our top story tonight
as the makeshift memorial in uvalde
grows so does the community's anguish
and anger
why 19 law enforcement officers waited
in a hallway for 47 minutes before
storming the classroom thinking the
shooter was barricaded and no children
were in danger
one of them was ten-year-old annabelle
rodriguez murdered in her own classroom
they let us let our baby get slaughtered
sacrificed
by their ass sitting behind a wall
texas governor greg abbott is now
promising a full investigation into the
police decisions which could lead to
discipline lawsuits and even criminal
charges against the police
there are people who deserve answers the
most and those are the families
whose lives have been destroyed
police chiefs in other cities say it's
not how their officers would have
responded
no question what we do
if the shooting is is ongoing we're
going to go in whether it's one officer
whether it's two whether it's three u.s
president joe biden who will visit and
mourn with the community sunday again
called on congress to pass stricter gun
control laws
we cannot outlaw tragedy i know
but we can make america safer
heroic teachers inside rob elementary
did everything they could to protect
their students one teacher's quick
thinking helped save several lives i
just stood up and looked out my window
that was right there
close by and i was like
there's a guy with a gun oh my god get
down ogborn told her students to get on
the ground as bullets came through the
window none of them was hurt as more
pictures emerged showing frightened
children fleeing the school through
windows one fourth grader jayden perez
said he had one thought as he ran for
safety
am i gonna die perez and other students
say they will never feel safe in their
school again the pain and fear from this
horrific mass shooting is growing in
this community as families plan funerals
to bury their loved ones
jennifer johnson global news washington
roughly four hours from the small
community of uvalde protests continued
today outside the national rifle
association's annual convention in
houston
protesters gathered for a second
straight day as one of america's most
powerful lobbyist groups met across the
street
yesterday thousands gathered outside the
event after nra leaders refused calls to
cancel their annual gathering in the
wake of the shooting
the tragedy in uvalde has been a focus
of the nra's convention this weekend
where some 55 000 people are expected to
attend but speakers including texas
senator ted cruz and former president
donald trump say the way to stop these
massacres is with more weapons not fewer
gun rights advocates say schools need
more protection with armed guards even
armed teachers but as heather urex west
reports research says otherwise
former u.s president donald trump says
the way to stop school shootings is with
more guns it's time to finally allow
highly trained teachers to safely and
discreetly concealed
carry let them concealed carry
as the age-old saying goes the only way
to stop a bad guy with a gun
is a good guy with a gun
schools trump told the nra crowd need
more security an armed officer on duty
at all times a single point of entry
with fencing and stronger doors texas
senator ted cruz agreed taking guns away
from these responsible americans
will not make them safer
nor will it make our nation
more secure to support his point trump
used recently released fbi data showing
armed citizens shot and killed four
active shooters in 2021 but that was
four out of 61 total incidents last year
a number that jumped from 40 the year
before army teachers is a really bad
idea introducing the risk of
a gun being mishandled by a teacher
where a student could gain access to
that gun
this possibility of accidental discharge
research has shown that most u.s
teachers parents and students are
opposed to arming teachers and having
armed officers at school did little to
prevent the deaths of students at the
columbine and parkland school shootings
in 1999 and 2018. if you look at
countries like australia
who chose to
eliminate all semi-automatic weapons and
all high-capacity weapons they seem to
have found great success
in stopping mass shootings but as a
powerful national lobby group the nra
has fought fiercely against all of those
changes
19 murdered children no match for the
group's fierce defense of american gun
rights heather urex west global news
houston texas
as the victims families try to cope with
their immeasurable grief they're finding
support from those who know the horrors
of gun violence all too well
those robbed of loved ones by other mass
shootings have bonded together to
support each other tonight jackson
proskow introduces us to a couple who
traveled to uvalde to share what they
learned from their own family's tragedy
[Laughter]
town square has become a place to grieve
a place to reflect on what was taken too
soon
it's here that we met sandy and lonnie
phillips they've come to comfort
survivors because they know their pain
this is our 20th
public mass shooting that we've
responded to since our daughter was
killed
their long journey to uvalde began in
2012. their daughter jessica was
visiting canada when she barely escaped
the shooting inside the toronto eaton
center it traumatized her she was very
affected by it and we could tell a
difference
in the way she lived her life
just seven weeks later still shaken by
that close call
jessica was killed in the mass shooting
at a movie theater near her home in
aurora colorado
after that sandy and lonnie made it
their mission to comfort people just
like themselves coming to uvaldi
straight from another massacre the
racist attack on a supermarket in
buffalo new york that left 10 dead when
it happened to us we didn't know what to
do next we didn't know what to expect
who was going to call who wasn't going
to call what we needed to do
so we put a survivor's tool kit together
for survivors of mass tragedies
in such a moment of darkness grief often
extends to the entire community i live
real close to rob school and my all my
kids went to school there so it's it's
very close to my heart my heart
my soul
goes out to these children
these lives that were lost innocently
into the family
i'm sorry i
all i can do is pray
for the families of the victims that
pain will last a lifetime
those impacted by other tragedies want
them to know that things can get better
in this moment sandy and lonnie see only
reason to push on we know that our laws
are going to eventually get better and
we know that eventually
they will change i think this time it's
going to be different
we hope yes
we hope and you can't give up hope you
just have to keep fighting
[Music]
jackson prosko global news uvalde texas
today u.s vice president kamala harris
called for a ban on assault weapons in
the u.s and the passage of much delayed
gun control legislation she made the
remarks following a funeral for the
oldest victim of the buffalo mass
shooting where she said the u.s is
experiencing an epidemic of hate
enough is enough
we will come together
based on what we all know we have in
common and we will not let those
people who are motivated by hate
separate us or make us feel fear
harris was not expected to speak at the
funeral for ruth whitfield the 86 year
old was among 10 people killed when a
white supremacist opened fire inside a
buffalo grocery store two weeks ago
today
on wednesday this week prime minister
justin trudeau signaled tougher gun
control is on the horizon in the wake of
the texas school massacre saying
canadians are unified in wanting to see
a reduction in gun violence in this
country this week on the west block
mercedes stephenson spoke with attorney
general david lametty on what the
government is planning mercedes what did
the attorney general say
colleen on monday public safety minister
marco mendicino will be introducing
legislation related to firearms this
comes in the wake of the mass shooting
at a uvalde texas elementary school
where 19 children and two teachers were
murdered
canada has much tougher gun laws than
the united states those who want to own
a gun must take a course pass an exam
and be approved by the rcmp
but that hasn't insulated canada from
gun crime either gang shootings in
vancouver and toronto leave communities
in fear and the mass shootings in quebec
city and port-au-prince nova scotia have
raised questions about whether gun laws
in canada are effective whether red
flags are being taken seriously enough
by police and how to stem the flow of
illegal firearms like those used in the
nova scotia shooting toronto police say
they believe part of the answer is the
judicial system that's tougher on gun
crime this week on the west block we
speak with attorney general david
lametty he says that despite getting rid
of mandatory minimums the liberal
government is open to changes that would
see tougher consequences for gun crime
including longer sentences and making it
harder to get bail i'm always open as a
minister of justice with with the you
know the
responsibility for the criminal code
to to look at ways of making the system
better so i'm certainly open when it
comes to handguns the liberals pledged
in the 2021 election that they would
allow cities to ban them themselves
mayors however have pushed back on that
pledge saying it should be the federal
government's responsibility
handguns are involved in the majority of
violent gun crimes in canada when i
asked lemedy why the federal government
is putting the onus on cities he
defended the government's record but
didn't rule out ottawa moving to ban
handguns you've alluded to the promise
that we made in the last electoral
campaign to work with municipalities
uh as uh as an option again i'm not
gonna preempt uh what minister mendocino
uh um
has in
as a matter of cabinet confidence
but i think i think it's fair to say
that this is on the top of the prime
minister's agenda what exactly the
federal government will propose on
monday remains to be seen but many
political observers expect some of it
will be a repeat of what died on the
order paper before the previous
parliament was dissolved for an election
we'll find out more of course on monday
colleen mercedes-stevenson thank you
and you can watch mercedes full
interview with david lametty on the west
block tomorrow right here on global
coming up russia conducts missile tests
while advancing a strategic goal
russia says it has successfully
test-fired a hypersonic zircon cruise
missile the defense ministry claims it
was fired from the berent sea and hit a
target in the white sea a distance of
about a thousand kilometers the missile
has been touted as a major breakthrough
in weapons development
moscow also claimed another victory in
ukraine today as it continues its
relentless assault on the country's
eastern donbass region
russia's defense ministry says the town
of liman has been quote completely
liberated from ukrainian nationalists
and he's now under the full control of
russian-backed forces if true it would
mark a significant victory and give
moscow control of a key railway hub in
eastern ukraine the claim comes as
vladimir putin held a lengthy call with
the leaders of france and germany where
he reportedly warned the continued
supply of arms to ukraine was dangerous
and could further destabilize the
situation
in indonesia 26 people are missing after
a ferry ran out of fuel and sank in bad
weather
43 people were on board when the ship
capsized off sulawesi island 17
passengers were rescued by passing
tugboats crews are searching the waters
for more survivors
chaotic scenes played out outside of
paris today impacting one of the world's
biggest sporting events
look at what has happened
i am in tears
i paint hundreds and hundreds of pounds
to come to this game tonight look at
these people look at all these poor
people
who've done exactly the same as me
i don't even want to watch this game
anymore now i don't want to walk in
stadium
riot police were seen making arrests
deploying pepper spray and using tear
gas on fans waiting to enter the
champions league final between liverpool
and real madrid
in a statement french police said
supporters had attempted to force their
way into the stadium
ahead finding middle ground why
ontario's election results next week
could have national implications
[Music]
you're watching global national
we're into the final days of campaigning
in ontario's general election with
voters headed to the polls on thursday
at this point it seems to be a race for
second place with a prominent prediction
being there will be no change at the top
but the vote could still have national
implications our chief political
correspondent david aiken is in toronto
today preparing for global's election
night coverage and david you argue this
election isn't just important for
ontario
well that's right colleen the polls have
been incredibly consistent in this
election the progressive conservative
government of doug ford the incumbent is
expected to repeat the majority victory
that it won in 2018 and i want you to
think why that might have some
implications for the federal
conservatives here is the map of the
2018 ontario election the results
there's 124 writings and the doug ford
pcs won more than 70 of them and they
are expected to win at least that many
on thursday so this same group of voters
that is about to send back-to-back
majority conservative governments to
queen's park
is also the same group of voters that is
the electoral backbone of justin
trudeau's liberals the federal liberals
in the last three elections have won 80
seats almost identical riding boundaries
70 seats to the pcs provincially 80 to
the federal liberals
so how is it that doug ford is getting
the same people to vote for him that
voted for justin trudeau's liberals one
reason doug ford is not an ideologue he
is presenting himself as a middle of the
road moderate conservative and that's
how you win votes in ontario a province
where the federal conservatives have
cratered in the last three federal
elections so as federal conservatives
decide between pierre polyev and
jean-cheray and patrick brown well they
may wish to look at these forward
back-to-back majorities if that is in
fact what is going to happen and
consider why it is that doug ford is so
successful in ontario colleen
and yet david new polling done
exclusively for global news indicates
even though ford may win there doesn't
seem to be a lot of enthusiasm for him
yeah our polling partner ipsos asked
ontarians which leader they preferred
for premier forty percent of those
surveyed say that would be doug four and
that's down a point from the beginning
of the campaign ndp leader andrea
horvath remember she's the official
opposition leader here in ontario she is
at 30 that's down about three points and
the new liberal leader stephen del duca
well he's at 22
that is up a point
and yet more than half of ontarians
surveyed told ipsos that you know what
they would prefer a different leader to
choose from on thursday colleen
david aiken in toronto david thank you
next when fashion meets politics the red
carpet statement that's taking a step
forward
[Music]
it was hardly the experience he was
expecting but a vancouver-based
indigenous film producer says he was
made to feel like a criminal after being
turned away from the red carpet at the
cannes film festival despite being
invited to walk it his crime
wearing traditional moccasins with his
tuxedo richard sussman has more
it is the height of culture and fashion
the red carpet at the con film fest amid
the tuxedos and gowns vancouver's kelvin
redverse was hoping to add moccasins to
the famous carpet a bow tie a black suit
and a pair of moccasins seemed like a
classy and subtle way to show some of my
culture some of my indigeneity
and
i was very much expecting that that
would be sort of accepted and normal red
verse a den a nation member was set to
appear on the red carpet last sunday
before the world premiere of les mandier
invited to khan part of a contingent of
indigenous producers pitching projects
and soaking in the atmosphere he wore
the required black tie with brown
moccasins there's always been this
understanding and this was communicated
to us that things like a kilt
is
generally understood as formal wear
within a certain nationality and
therefore if you show up in a kilt that
that's okay
red verse now home in vancouver says
there was a back and forth among staff
and security even a french-speaking
colleague tried to help but ultimately
he was only allowed to proceed after
changing back to his brown leather shoes
after being excited for
weeks to be able to bring my culture to
this red carpet event to be told
get out this isn't welcome here
um
is something that stings in it and it
still stings
the toronto-based indigenous screen
office filed a complaint on behalf of
redverse and a day later the head of the
con red carpet apologized
redverse was then invited back for
canadian director david cronenberg's
crimes of the future this time with his
moccasins on and the first person who we
bumped into
who saw the moccasins had the same
reaction nope nope nope
but the next person behind them who's a
little higher up saw who we were
knew the conversation that had been had
knew what we were wearing and said yes
let them through
that was my favorite part of the
festival
work now being done with khan to
showcase what culturally important
clothing for indigenous people looks
like and to make sure this doesn't
happen again richard zusman global news
victoria
and in case you were wondering reuben
austlin's triangle of sadness a satire
on modern day capitalism has won the
palm door for best film at this year's
cannes film festival maybe one day it'll
be kelvin redfers and that's global
national for this saturday night i'm
colleen christie tonight's your canada
is calgary please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching i'll see you back
here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you